hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
the most central character in franz
kafka's
short story in the penal colony
is the explorer you can say that the
officer
is almost equally central but and that's
true to a certain degree
but the explorer is the one who runs the
course of the entire story
and we're really getting the
story primarily from the perspective
of the explorer it's not told in first
person it's told in third person
but the explorer is you might say the
moral voice
of the story so we can't strictly
identify him with
kafka as author but it's the closest
that we're going to get
and you could say that well there's
other characters as well
there's the soldier there is the
condemned
man they don't really have that much of
a role other than being you know
involved in what's happening
it's really about the explorer who is
making a judgment about what the
officer is doing and telling him and you
can say that there's
a third main character who is
in some respects outside of the story by
necessity
that's the former commandant who the
officer
was the assistant and really the only
remaining follower of
there's also mentioned and who plays an
important role in the story
the new commandant as well and so what
we can see going on here
is one way of reading this there's a
struggle going on
over the nature of justice and its
application
between the officer as the
representative of the old commandant
and the new commandant and the explorer
is an outsider who's coming in who is
being
invited in fact implored to
judge between these these two sides
and their merits when it comes to
justice
so we should talk first about the
previous commandant
the officer and the machine
what we see here is that there is a
deliberate
innovation in the penal or justice
system
within the penal colony you could say
that in a way
it's kind of a utopian scheme
on the part of the previous commandant
aided by the officer and we're told
by the officer who may be an unreliable
narrator he may be lying he may be
embellishing but let's just say that
he's actually
being accurate about the the case the
previous commandant was
sort of a jack of all trades perhaps
master of of some as well a great
innovator a charismatic person
and he comes up with this this new way
of executing criminals by
imposing the sentence on their very body
through an inscription of justice
which is supposed to produce
understanding through horrible pain it's
written
on the person's body and it also
provides
a spectacle in which the
other members of the penal colony can
come
and take place according to the officer
they actually have to put like
fences and guards up to keep people from
mobbing this it's almost like a rock
concert in in the type of spectacle
that we're talking about you know people
get really into it
and you know it's it's not that big of a
stretch we know that
in previous uh political systems
executions were often times of public
spectacle
even celebration in some cases
and so you know this is not implausible
perhaps again there's some some
embellishing that's taking place and so
this is not just
a practice this represents
a whole let's call it attitude
and regime towards the imposition
of justice justice against criminality
justice which is not supposed to just
efface the individual
or you know destroy them or remove them
from the society but justice that is
supposed
to through the medium of pain
inflicted on the prisoners own body
justice that is supposed to produce
a grasp on the part of the condemned of
what it was that they
did wrong what it was that they violated
and we know that there's there's a lot
of other elements to this as well
the officer reveals to us that there's
no trial
there's no accusations actually heard
and defended against
the prisoner may not even know that they
have been accused
until they're let out and put naked into
the machine
and they undergo this this treatment
which turns out to be a sentence
and they have this horrible pain all
across their body
by being pierced with needles having
inscribed upon them
not only the sentence itself not only
the commandment which they
violated usually just a single line but
all sorts of embellishments from head to
toe
as well going around several times with
the needles going deeper and deeper
for at least six hours until they
suddenly
get the message on their own flesh of
what the
verbal commandment is that they violated
so this is this is an entire way of
approaching
justice and as i mentioned it's it's in
some respect utopian it's supposed to be
an improvement upon previous ways of
administering justice
but it can also and we see this through
the eyes of the explorer be
something very unjust
inhumane you know a form of torture
in fact and so the the there's a present
day conflict in the story
the explorer is being called upon to be
a deciding
voice in a conflict that is taking place
largely being won by the new commandant
but not entirely so because it's being
fought against this
officer who is trying to maintain this
this
rather you know new tradition now become
traditional of this this this regime of
the machine
right and they're they're go what we say
where they're in conflict or at
loggerheads
about it neither of them can get
entirely what they want it seems like
the new
commandant is winning and so the new
commandant according to the
officer is bringing in the explorer to
be the deciding voice the the explorer
is gonna
even with an offhand remark like well we
don't do torture where i come from or
where i come from we actually let people
have a trial
that can be used any offhand remark can
be
employed as a tool to end this tradition
but the the new commandant who doesn't
approve of this machine has found all
sorts of other ways
of subverting this regime
a couple examples of this the prisoner
throws up uh and and the officer goes
into this litany of complaints
oh they're supposed to fast for a day
before their sentence
right this isn't supposed to be the way
things work and
you know we need replacement parts for
this who wouldn't throw up when putting
into their
their mouth a gag that's been in the
mouth of hundreds of condemned men
i and then he goes on further i try to
get spare parts for the machine in the
time of the old commandant we had you
know basically warehouses of spare parts
the machine could be fixed all the time
it was in prime condition
now even just to get a strap a leather
strap
i have to take the old one and submit it
and it takes weeks before i get a new
one so he's going on and on about how
the
new commandant is attempting to
you know phase out this practice the new
commandant can't just say listen
we're done with this and get rid of the
machine
instead he chokes it off he makes sure
that there's
fewer and fewer occasions for the
machine to be used
and this is reflected by the people of
the
prison colony who don't come to see the
performances anymore they're not part of
the spectacle as a matter of fact
it seems like public opinion now has at
least according to the officer
turned against them and so the officer
is the last remnant the last holdout
for this this in his view wonderful way
of administering justice and the officer
views the explorer as a
prime opportunity to get his point
across
he says listen you have to be very
careful about what you say
and i by the way i have a plan
i want you to
help me out with this you're going to
tell everybody you know in this this uh
gathering you're going to tell everybody
what you really think about this he says
the first thing is is to be as reticent
as possible today regarding your verdict
on these proceedings don't say
anything or give very curt answers and
then tomorrow there's going to be a
large
conference of all the high
administrative officials
the common input commandant presiding
and this will be turned into a public
spectacle
uh you will certainly be invited to this
conference if
if uh you know if you don't then
make sure that you get there tomorrow
you're sitting in the commandants box
with the ladies he keeps looking up to
make sure that you're there
and then i'll get up and i'll say there
was an execution
yesterday and then the commandant is
going to seize the opportunity and say
aha what do you objective
person explorer from another country
what did you make of this execution
and that's when we're gonna drop the
trap on this terrible new commandant
you're gonna say that you thought it was
you know warranted
you're gonna say that it is it is good
he says
um then at last you can speak out i
don't know how i'm gonna endure the
tension of waiting for that moment
don't put any restraint on yourself when
you make your speech publish the truth
aloud
lean over the front of the box shout yes
indeed shout your verdict your
unshakeable
conviction at the commandment you do it
however you want to
tell them how they've been you know
abusing
the the the regime of the machine by
giving us
no spare parts and requiring us to put a
filthy gag
in somebody's mouth tell them what
you've seen
and the explorer says you know
i will in fact give a verdict i'm not
going to give a verdict in this public
way and i'm going to do it behind closed
doors
but you and i are not in agreement about
any of this stuff officer
and that is the verdict that he's going
to give
there is a really great passage here
that reveals to us
how kafka is positioning this this
person
he says from the very beginning the
explorer had no doubt about what answer
he must give
i think the beginning of this speech
rather than the beginning of seeing the
machine
he had experienced too much to have any
uncertainty here he was fundamentally
honorable and unafraid now is kafka
being ironic there
and saying well maybe he isn't honorable
no i think actually
what is playing out here shows that we
have somebody
who is motivated in many respects
by honor by duty by moral obligation
by we can say justice in the
the broad sense so he says now facing
the soldier and the condemned man he did
hesitate
for as long as it took to draw one
breath at last however
he said as he had to no now
did he hesitate to about what he should
do
no he didn't hesitate about that he only
hesitated about expressing it
because what this meant is he had to say
to somebody
you're wrong i am not going to go along
with this
i am not going to follow along with your
scheme
i'm not going to say that this is the
right way to do things
and so he says i do not approve of your
procedure
even before you took me into your
confidence i was already wondering
whether it would be
my duty to intervene and whether my
intervention would have the slightest
chance of success i realized to whom i
ought to turn to the commandant of
course
you have made that fact even clearer but
without having strengthened my
resolution on the contrary
your sincere conviction has touched me
even though it cannot
influence my judgment so he can say that
that listen
i get that this is really important to
you
i understand that you are so invested
in this there's even like points to what
you're saying that are not
you know horrible and you know
inspiring somebody with a sense of
disgust or terror
but i'm going to put that aside because
my duty requires me to say that this is
wrong
fundamentally wrong what you're doing i
must judge the procedure
the regime that you have here to be
unjust
so i have to render judgment and then
we see the character of this being
carried out
in two different ways during the
self-execution
first of all he allows
the officer to do what they're
you know what he's going to do right
which is to release the condemned
man and then he puts himself
into the machine the officer says
be just is what is going to be inscribed
on
my body and there's a very important
line here after
the description of how the officer is
putting himself into the machine
the explorer bit his lips and said
nothing he knew very well what was going
to happen
but he had no right to obstruct the
officer in anything
if the judicial procedure which the
officer cherished were really so near
its
end possibly as a result of his own
intervention to which he felt himself
pledged
then the officer was doing the right
thing
in his place the explorer would have not
acted
otherwise so again he's motivated by
honor duty justice and he says
this self-execution is indeed the right
thing i would do that if
if it were me as the officer so
he allows it but then the machine
malfunctions
the machine breaks down and
instead of providing this
means of enlightenment it's just causing
horrible injury
and suffering to the the
officer right and so he says the
explorer was greatly troubled the
machine was obviously
going to pieces it's silent working was
a delusion
he had a feeling he must stand by the
officer since the officer was no longer
able to look after himself he's trying
to figure out what can i do
to end this and of course what they do
doesn't help at all
by the time that they they get the
officer and they pull the machine out
he's already been pierced in the head by
the spike
but he he did what he could so the
explorer is showing
not just his verdict on the wrongness of
this he's also
showing that his verdict is one that is
as best as one can be objective
now there is more to the story
about what's going on and i think that
we can talk about the danuma
of the story with this discussion of the
social condemnation
of the former commandant they they go
to the tea house and in the tea house
they say the old man's buried there the
priest wouldn't let him lie in the
church yard
nobody knew where to bury him for a
while in the end they buried him here
the officer never told you about that
because of course that's what he was
most ashamed of
he even tried to dig the old man up but
he was always chased away
so where is the grave it's underneath
a table right says
they led the explorer right up to the
back wall
and they pushed one of the tables aside
underneath it is a gravestone so
that's how much social condemnation
there has been
already of the methods of the old
commandant and there's a gravestone that
says here rest the old commandant his
adherents who must now be nameless have
dug up the dug this grave and set up
this stone
there's a prophecy that after a certain
number of years the commandant will rise
again
and lead his adherents from this house
to recover the colony have
faith and weight and so the explorer
is seeing the last remnants of an old
way of doing things which was a new way
of doing things
something that was supposed to be more
just but turned out in some respects to
be even
more unjust and this is what it has been
relegated to it hasn't gone away
entirely
it still has traces but they're becoming
ineffective
and the explorer's verdict plays a
central role in this and a verdict that
is given
from a position of at least some sort of
justice
about the nature of justice within the
penal colony
you